Запис Розпочато перш ніж як То кажуть, передати управління, моєму колеги Павло Володимирович особистісна мотивація навіщо це є необхідним, моя кар'єра звати розробника програмного забезпечення завершилась 2 007 року, останні студенти які були запрошені мною, на роботу.
інтерфейс до баз даних його просто інтерфейс мої колеги виконували дії з відповідного інтерфейсу, апаратною частиною і таке інше.
І цей проект завершився тим, що в нас просто власне в Україні, змінилося законодавство не і через це те, програмне забезпечення яке розробилося стало забороненим в нас зникло фінансування Ось так воно завершилося від артефактів завершилося Відповідні.
зникне що ж а тепер передаю слово Павло володимировичу заворучку який, як то кажуть, є був вже студентом трохи іншої групи не iн 4 а дещо як то кажуть, можливо, трохи пізніше Павло Володимирович.
October right now. Is the Halom voodoo provided was semester.
Just call more builds practitioners came out to the eagile.
методи і Чи Взагалі вважаєте, що вони потрібні?
У когось є думка.
Запрошую як То кажуть, вільний мікрофон.
Ну, я так розумію, що це розподілення на більш дрібні завдання проєкт.
Загалом Це також 1 з критеріїв цілком ще й дай.
Ну, можливо, це коли поступає якийсь проєкт з командою він ділиться на якісь підгрупи і розподіляється серед команди на якийсь по якимись критеріями наприклад, якщо це від візуал це роблять а якщо це база пакету це робить букет пластичним мовам.
Також цілком гарний варіант ще можливо, якісь варіанти. Є.
Ну це по факту підхід до управління певними проєктами.
Зручно у компанії і тому вони змінюють його під свої потреби загалом якщо є ще думки.
Ми можемо ще послухати. Якщо ні, то можемо перейти до більше поглибленої частини з гнучкими методами.
Добре так Сергій Лексич У мене мабуть, ані є можливість. Шартикран. Все добре.
Давайте далі.
Се я.
Так, скажіть вам витника.
Добре азон загалом ми будемо розглядати лише скром фрейморг Але для чутка. Причин. Тому що зазвичай скромно По-перше, він є найбільш популярнішим серед компаній перших камерках, тому він є більш таким класичним і основним.
Так.
коли вам кажуть, що в цьому проєкті, є команда розробник наприклад, якийсь уявний магазин в якому є команда розробників що виявляєте, під команду.
Розробників.
Ну, це коли у кожного, є свої обов'язки в ковіді, хто щось не щось відповідає.
Так.
Добре, хто конкретно це буде наприклад, якщо це магазин кого ми враховуємо, що побуто в команді, розробників.
Ну, це продавець людина, на складі яка управляє повністю складом, хто ще там Ну, адміністрація, якась магазину, тобто ось все всі люди які працюють у магазині.
До тих бізнес-вимог став ставить менеджмент якщо ми будемо розглядати навіть зовсім іншу галузь розробка ігор то там наприклад, команду розробники будуть входити і письменники які будуть писати сюжет і дизайнери, кар'єру, це будуть як і дизайнери, третей моделей тобто буде
продукт і про його технічні можливості.
Приходячи до другого пункту це все власне, власник продукт. Або продиктований це є людина більш бізнесу.
Частіше за все Ця людина буде організовувати лише деяку, частину а Тобто, це все ж таки, основа це розмови, з клієнтами або степлторами тому що розробники дуже рідко комунікують насправді з клієнтами у більшості своїй реалії покажуть що це важче не всі розробники є дуже
програм для бухгалтерського обліку то вашим стейкхолдерам будуть Саме такі бухгалтери, які використовуватимуть цю програму і будуть давати вам якісь вимоги на основі яких ви будете розробляти щось.
А Тобто, якщо ви наприклад, хочете. Як я сказав, в п'ятницю. Закинути якесь оновлення, на робочі сервера.
Це має все ж таки буде обговорюватися з продуктованором Тому що ця людина відповідає це все тут центр людина буде говорити з клієнтами, Чому система не працює не мають бути.
І Останній елемент. В цьому всьому це є справ. Майстер Загалом скрам майстер в організаціях у невеликих організаціях він рідко присутній Тобто якщо ви починаєте працювати в стартапі.
загалом ці ролі будуть використовуватися і в нашому випадку у нашому випадку скрам майстер це буде людина зі студентів яку можна буде обрати власне таки комунікувати з продуктом.
скра, майстра з продуктовна це все короля поки що чи є можливо, у вас якісь питання уточнення.
Які б хотіли почути стосовно ролей.
У нас майстер це тобто, про що кажуть, ще лід чи ні, ну, тобто, не зовсім.
Не зовсім якщо ми говоримо про літа. Або про керуючого технічної частини А тут є 2 варіанти перший варіант це інша назва може бути чаптерліт Наприклад, якщо це модель з по файллю назви інші сотні 100 лишається 1 й та ж сама лід це той, хто управляє технічної команди тобто він буде по
Ого зрозуміло.
храм, як організовувати зустрічі. І читача так Вибачте, мені треба двері відкрити я через секунду.
Власне кажучи, якщо мова йде про відповідну майстра це приблизно так як для чайної царини майстер чайної церемонії саму чайну церемонію виконують її учасники Але майстер чайної церемонії слідкує за дотриманням усіх, процедур.
Ну, Зрозуміло? Дякую.
Можливо? Ще Якісь запитання по ролях. Є.
В прямому це замі і тоді продовжимо власники церемонії загалом назви досить такі незвично і в більшості що церемонія є чимось непотрібним, Проте церемонії є важливим, елементом і вони виконують свою оцінку.
Ми розглянемо декілька церемоній власне, таке 2 дуже пов'язаних між собою.
10 і розробники мають постійний стрес тим, що вони не можуть закінчити розробку то для цього існує рефспектива у якій ми оглядаємо кожен з цих пунктів а далі.
Так, як ми оглянули і Спирт закінчився. Ми робимо планування. Зменто Загалом, воно є.
виконати уявимо, що в нас є 5 розробників, а якщо ми візьмемо ті ж самі 40 завдань то скажімо, 1 розробник може робити 2 одне завдання, в день якщо вони будуть легким, тобто, реально, встигнути зробити ті завдання.
методом і частіше за все використовується це є а користувацькі льори понт по факту це є просто число, яке використовується для оцінки складності завдань.
Вони використовують ці баначі. Послідовності. Тобто це наприклад, складність, може йти.
обговорень. Так, розробники можуть казати що Ось це Немає сенсу це ми не будемо використовувати тому що воно.
Не співпадає таке потрібно зробити щось інше. Тому що продукт не може самостійно, вирішити що потрібно що можливо Тому для цього існує планування на яких ми можемо обговорити ці моменти.
Загалом, далі як було все вказано в нас є щоденний стандарт, Загалом, назва походить від історично від того, що люди стояли під час цього всього Тобто в компаніях, раніше.
І загалом Останній елемент огляд сприту є більш елементом в якому ви просто показуєте стикдором або клієнтам що ви зробили за цей період точніше, за все це може бути дана версія вашого продукту що дуже часто робиться якийсь продукт щоб показати його клієнтам якщо ці клієнти
вкладають гроші, у Вашу компанію, вам треба показати дуже гарно ваш продукт що він працює чи навіть якщо він не працює у огляд спренту, це Фактично, двохтичне після двох тижневого відрізку ми показуємо те, що ми зробили і презентуємо це дуже гарних умов.
можливо, ви не знаєте що робити далі, чи Можливо, вимоги більш адекватними. І ви, хочете щось якоїсь допомоги, так Сергій осіч.
Дякую. Павло володимировичу а як ви дивитесь на те щоб ми все ж таки як-то зробили посередині тижня. У межах консультації ми визначимо для всіх Ну, хоча б 2 рази на тиждень звичка зустріч там 10 15 хвилин з цього питання.
Допомога Тоді якісь думки сонця так?
Це в принципі, реально зробити я думаю, у нас не так багато занять тому думаю, окей.
Добре.
За тільки можемо визначитися коли саме Зараз, я сюди, скину, наш розклад приблизно глянете коли буде вам зручний час і нам.
тижні не почнеться наступного тижня. Розпочнеться перший спонт і загалом коли той стан закінчиться.
У нас буде своя ретроспектива який ми можемо оглянути побачите Можливо, ми якісь робили помилки, або щось такого загалом, перш ніж ми підемо до схем артефактів, Знову ж таки, Чи якісь питання, можливе уточнення щось цікавить стосунки.
Того, що обговорювали.
Поки немає, мабуть.
Можна показати, власне, якщо це було з магазином одягу. Го ми розробляли головну сторінку може бути розрахований на конкретну і операцію.
Або імплементації.
На цьому частина з презентацією і з чайлом у нас закінчується.
І власне, таке ми можемо перейти до більш практичної частини, а це нас буде організаційні елементи, тому що поки що в нас немає ні.
Створених принципів, не створених проєктів Перше запитання. Все ж таки нам треба утворити команди і тут може бути 2 методи або все ж таки ви можете обрати з ким ви хочете бути я думаю, що так як у вас 12 Дай наскільки я пам'ятаю, правильно то це може бути якраз 3 команди по 4 людини.
занятті. Але ви знаєте, що вони будуть тому це питання треба було б обговорити зараз і загалом, створити загальні команди щоб можна було далі обговорювати проєкти.
Є якісь Побажання можливе.
Хтось хоче бутиски.
Так? Складно.
Давайте нам хоча б 5 хвилин, Адже якщо ми зараз між собою, поспілкувалися і вирішили хто де і як хоче а вже з рештою. Буквально через 5 хвилин, то ми вам повідомили, кожен, запропонує тим, хто хоче такі, найактивніші з якими хотіли би.
Можна будь ласка? Почути які саме проекти, будуть.
Добре.
Так це залом. Буде наступним пунктом тут більше обговорень можна обрати у нас є список проєктів, зараз можу скинути їх в Чад.
Ось тобто є 5 проектів, які можна обрати але знову ж таки, якщо команда хоче розробляти щось щоб вони хотіли для себе або це підходило для їхніх дисертаційних праць, у рамках проєкту то також можна взяти потрібно враховуватись.
Та має бути веб-сайт, тобто веб-розробка щось буде не відноситись до цього на якийсь інтерфейс, а саме такий який веб-застосунок і на основі цього можна бути загалом, і створювати знову ж таки, завдання можуть змінюватися і ці проекти лише є прикладами того що може потрапити.
Так. На Поточний момент ми маємо власний склад однієї команди і до цієї команди, включені.
Як тих, хто наразі з нами знаходиться так і тих, хто не були на занятті ви використовуєте власні канали комунікації, Але ж якщо буде така, можливість саме для обговорення дій які стосуються із проєктом.
Доцільним. Було б створення такого каналу, де власне Продак Оунер Павло Володимирович і я як стейкхолдер міг би долучитися для оперативного розв'язання проблем щоб Знову ж таки, не чекати від одного стандарту до іншого.
Дякую.
Я думаю, що можна було б у телеграмі як 1 варіант комунікації створити так групу для кожної команди у нашому випадку лише покладнає тому можна було б створити я думаю, що контакти Сергій олексійович у вас є а в реакції чи є мої тому.
Вони О, контактів Сергій Олексійович нікого немає. Але Цього разу Заради цього Я спробую зробити давайте спробуємо Насамперед, хто у нас є головний Продакт-унер Я дозволю собі узяти те, що стосується посилання на профіль Павла володимировича одну хвильку.
Як це скопіювати посилання так, Здається, посилання я скопіював зараз його дочату Оце в телеграмі як Павло Володимирович.
І тепер мені потрібно мабуть, себе знайти також відповідно у чаті я не знаю, наскільки мені це вдасться 5, Ну, в крайньому випадку павло володимирович спробує. Мене додати хвильку не бачу власний профіль Ой, щось погане, в мене з поширенням Ну, нічого будемо виправлятися.
Так, казали ви можете спробувати зараз створити групи Тоді в телеграмі па ще є толограм-пра.
Як Основний Ага. Добре!
Ми вже створили.
Так, але поки що не бачиш себе доданого?
Зараз.
За газ!
Добре, скажете, тому що можливо, що в мене вiмдесятна, неможливість додати мене до груп його треба буде пошукати я не впевнений, що вони зараз стрімкі значення.
І якось мені потрібно включитися. Павло Володимирович ви знаєте, яке в мене хоча б посилання.
Я тут час, зможу додати але не впевнений, що воно у нас є, тому, що у вас мабуть, немає ні пнеймо не впевнена, як вона генеруватиме так, але астп є, ще але ні вона лише дозволяє комусь кинути напряму в телеграмі але як посиланням.
Так.
Можливо. Так.
Розв'яжемо.
Так.
А все ж таки я мав налаштування, що не можна було додавати у групи, зараз а має бути така можливість.
Бачу просування. Зараз.
Так. Є. Ще?
Дякую. Я теж зміг приєднатися Дякую.
Дало назву можете придумати будь-яку. Кочити немає обмежень тому але зараз це не є загалом дуже важливим, наступним елементом це все ж таки, буде вибір проєкту який би для вашої команди.
Був найбільш цікавим і загалом він також може співвідноситись до того, що вам буде потрібно зробити для вашої колекційної роботи це може бути окремий елемент але все ж таки я не тому що ми зможемо зробити проєкт лише для однієї людини.
Для кваліфікаційної роботи, тому було б добре. Все ж таки щоб це було щось загальне до списку який був представлений Проте, Загалом, ми Відкриті до будь-яких побажань це може бути будь-який Веб-сервіс застосунок в рамках коштів.
Було б цікаво застосунок, зробити але поки який саме складно вирішити, на яку саме тему.
Так, це Станіслав так, плавно переходять у свою кваліфікаційну щоб йому ще зробили.
Ні-ні. Я вже роблю.
Ну.
Це буде чудово, якщо частину відповідного застосунку, ви зможете розтягнути по своїм кваліфікаційним все добре.
Так. Такий варіант також можливо.
Загалом, невпевнений можемо звісно, вам дати ще 5 хвилин. Якщо це допоможе для вибору.
Звісно, проекту.
Або можливо, як то кажуть, зробити зараз такий самий п'ятьхвилинний стандарт більшість команди тут які в кожного члена команди будуть думки з цього приводу.
Такий варіант, можемо піти тобто Кожен може висловити свою думку своє бачення який проєкт, ви б хотіли бачити або якщо ви не маєте своєї побажань ви можете погодитися з побажаннями іншого.
Як ти бажаєш і почати перші.
У нас є перша команда і є у цій команді. Номер перший запросив.
Ну так давайте я спробую ми так трошечки вже обговорили, думаємо з приводу блогу але по факту розглянути і приблизно уявити що може нас очікувати то по факту дуже схожі процеси всюди тільки грубо кажучи не знаю, ми думаємо напевно зупинимося на блозі.
То добре, 100 інших. Так, другий нас по списку йде степове гранік.
Ой! У цій команді тому я теж думаю про блог ніяких заперечень не.
Добре добре перешнаю заверто.
В.
Університету Олександрівни скоріш за все, Наразі проблеми зв'язком.
Нічого так, окура станіслав Ваша думка.
Ну вісто зупинились ми на блозі, але саме на яку тему? Таке питання для обговорення тому блок прикольно зробити саме на яку тему, ще може вирішимо за цей день можливо, поки дуже складно.
Щось не лізе на яку можна зробити але блог, це круто.
Добре. Загалом це і є наші ціллю щоб зорієнтуватися хоча б на типі проєкту а далі вже не на основі цього ми будемо гнучко переходити і створювати завдань.
вам, скину наймили посилання щоб ми з вами сформували проєкт і мили в нас у мене а ще є Тому я зараз спробую їх Сергій оцієш так?
Дякую. Павло Володимирович, Власне кажучи, але в нас наразі є ще та людина, яка не увійшла до першої команди Максим, Бощенко разом із нами, можливо, користуючись випадком ми запропонуємо йому, саме спробувати скоординувати другу команду, максиме що скажете?
Ага.
Тулку.
Не знаю, а хто залишився.
Так. Що ж давайте подивимося, хто в нас власне кажучи, залишився у нас найперше залишилося ви і мають бути ще шестеро з тих, кого запам'ятю я можу назвати це Олександр Харченко, раз далі.
Власне а Ого, а далі в мене пам'ять. На жаль, відмовляє Можливо, яна юріївна нам допоможе сказати або написати хто у нас ще може бути не у складі Другої команди.
У нас є кривав'ящук. У нас є Кучеро-фєєв Це 3 троє які за кордоном.
І не завжди мають можливість ходити на заняття у нас ще є ступак який працює якщо я не помиляюсь.
На індивідуальному плані вчинка що є.
У 4.
У мене команда з людей, що за кордоном, часовий пояс плюс 2 людини що працюють.
Ну, Візьми собі люкривом ящука. Він доволі непогано. Працює Я тобі вже написала кого можна було б взяти тобі в команду.
Ні, кучеряв Богдан він зараз вже в змозі працювати. Він мені теж писав.
Та що харченка Візьми Він також доволі непогано. Все, може зробити Діма Візуал може зробить.
А те, що деякі з ваших колег, знаходиться в іншому часовому поясі, може бути якраз гарною на нагодою для того, відповідний скандал зробити наприклад, не обов'язково вдень тощо.
А десь ближче, ввечері, як то кажуть, коли в нас вдень в Америці, ніч але коли в нас вечір в Америці, ранок не Тобто, можна спробувати ті, хто знаходяться у Франції, в них відставання від нас наскільки на 2 години не має бути проблем.
І так.
Ну, і бачу Максим вийшов тому мабуть, можливо, проблеми, зі зв'язком, звісно, так, поки обговорювали я знайшов мейли Окрім електрон занадто.
Що ж?
Хоча б не зміг розшифрувати Тому, будь ласка, якщо можете скинути або тут або в телеграмі.
Якщо ще раз, скинув, у мене не чує десь її.
І я Перепрошую, пригадав ще суганяка у вашій групі. Ми з ним колись працювали з курсової роботи не Гадаю, може теж приєднатися.
Приєднатися він То може але особисто я його на заняттях не бачу і я не впевнена, в його вміннях.
Тобто, поки.
володіння технологіями. У нього на той момент були.
Владислав Владиславович якщо не помиляюсь.
Вийшло знайти Мейл.
Тому що список то у мене є але зі списками, витрат зрозуміло.
Так, цим Поки Я десь Надсилала І Сергій Олексійовичу зараз.
У.
Важливий звісно, зараз перевірю що джмейл. Покаже імено, було б добре.
Проте, на жаль.
На жаль, не показ.
Я сподіваюся, що в нас є лідер команд хто перший номер то і зробимо на певний момент лідером.
Які будуть відповідальні за Ці складові комунікації.
Тоді, Павло Володимирович будь ласка, до Осани мабуть.
Саме в чомусь декілька проте а ті так коли відправив вибачаюсь, Ну, так треба.
Багато Ось знайшли зараз відправлю. На Ваші кошти відправив я можу відправити. Які пошти.
На ось я відправив запрошення. Тобто загалом там буде.
Інструкція до реєстрації. Хтось може показати екран і я можу загалом пояснити, що треба буде обрати там немає нічого складного.
І інші зможуть також слідкувати що було загалом простіше.
Василь Васильович Я також Додав Оба Ти Фрак.
Дякую. Павло Володимирович.
Треба вийти на головнийника.
А з вашого боку, я як то кажуть, покажу свій екран, а ви покеруєте що я маю зробити Отже, я вмикаю демонстрацію, не і я бачу, що в берни павло загородко через асану надіслав запрошення, на приєднання я в васані вже зареєстрований тому я натискаю усю кнопку.
Ні. Там?
В'ю прочект і далі Ну, далі я чекаю.
Може питання: я натиснув за посиланням і мені треба заходить через голлаука або реєструватися саме через осану чи це без різниця?
Загалом можете це черевикове вокал також той що на прийшов запрошення, тобто можете загалом зареєструватися на пройде цілком нормально.
А Ну ти що?
Добре.
Станіслава Покажіть ваш екран. Як то кажуть це буде для мене корисною для всіх.
Зараз Добре.
Скажіть, вам видно.
Угу. Так.
Зараз Я розумію. Треба перемістити. Зуб поясню. Дивіться я натиснув на вівторок.
Ми бачимо.
Мене одразу вже сюди. Переходимо.
Ну.
Тут Я проходжу ліса сюжет.
Так Можете вказати певне ім'я.
З сумнів.
У.
От і вас загалом досить швидко додало до проекту е Наприклад, можете натиснути на дошка поряд зі списком.
Бачу!
І тут салом, як і пояснювалось, буде пекло продукту пекло що треба буде зробити, або туди процес розробки що в процесі і загалом, те, що буде зроблено га?
Угу. Це Як Ее тi ти так, осе за кого?
Тобто вони будуть розв'язати просто що асар не є спрощеним, Тобто тут немає окремої сторінки.
Для пеклогу як наприклад, жира а будуть лише такі окремі колони.
Угу. Добре. Цікаво.
Так стосовно інших чи вийшло? Зареєструватися і зайти.
Мені Можна призупиняти так демонструє екран.
Так-так.
У мене на пошті. Нічого немає.
І в мене так само.
Де-но Може, спробувати ще раз, надіслати Можливо, десь щось, скопіювалось неправда.
Тому Давайте спробуємо. Повторно.
Разі я увійшов і бачу, що власне у складі є надіслано повідомлення, на фоксбетці раз вероніка степова вони ще не прийняли відповідні запрошення.
Я повторно відправу Так, з крісла.
Дивіться, щойно побачив Адвент-феріал тобто на місяць. Нам доступного оксана чи це можливо?
Якісь функції тільки після залу.
Вам буде на місці але.
Вашого дозволу. Я Тут Ми розпочинаємо з цієї версії яка є безоплатною після те як того, як місяць впливає ми профінансуємо невідповідне Наступний місяць для того, щоб ви Крім того, що оволоділи функціональністю.
Безоплатного продукту, подивилися яку комерційну функціональність, вони пропонують до того моменту, ви вже як-то кажуть, зможете це і гарно помацати і з'ясувати де у вас можуть бути обмеження.
Добре Дякую за відповідь.
Так? Стосовно запрошень, чи прийшли зараз.
Так, прийшли.
Добре яно як?
Так? Чи вже зареєстрували.
Тоді я зараз включу демонстрацію. Екрану і загалом поясню за асано і що треба буде робити.
У Ее, ще.
І митний кран.
Так. Так.
Добре загалом 5.
Якщо можна було трохи збільшити контр плюс пару раз.
Ах це у мене нова версія зараз Дозвольте я відкрию ве перші продукти.
Тому що в них є додаток.
Тому, мабуть, буде простіше.
Використати для збільшення так секунду. То буде так і так ні, Ось це має бути.
Так. Зараз видно?
Так.
Чудово.
І кут плюс пару для тих, у кого ці зором не Дуже О, дякую.
колонки які використовуються в гнучких методах, що ж треба зробити аж Ну, тут крісло.
процес розробки і коли закінчуйте випертягуйте його в строк Загалом, ще було зрозуміло, що ми зараз спробуємо з вами створити тут є додати завдання А таск ми додаємо можна на нього зараз я зум перетягну трошечки.
Сюди можна на нього плацу і Загалом, вибиває ось такий інтерпрес у якому ми пишемо повне завдання. А тут питання, наприклад, якщо ми хочемо створювати блог перше питання, буде все ж таки м'яке б завдання. Нам треба було створити з цього нам потрібно почати.
Функціонал, блогу, тобто що саме він повинен включати?
Так. Це опис Загалом, нам треба буде зрозуміти, що буде функціонал. Тобто, нам треба буде створити вимоги так загалом.
треба вказувати які конкретні частини і пробувати їх робити намагатися робити їх якомога маленьким А тобто якщо ми говоримо про все ж таки створення блогу перше, частіше за все що день, створення.
При позиторі на від хати тут вам треба буде складати проєкт ваш разом. І Якось над ним працювати можна було б створити завдання це створення Можете назвати скоріше але Загалом, можна не знати це створення інфраструктури.
Як є за історію? Яка буде Загалом, займатися? Цим ми можемо втекти. Від цього Що ж.
продукту? Хочу від що.
додамо якусь таблицю до сайту ні нам треба розуміти, для чого ми це робимо де створення взису 5 базити.
можемо взяти створити тепло з історій відгад і тут є конкретні ось ми можемо експантувати кажуть: більше під завдань.
Під завдання. Частіше за все в даному випадку можна використовуватися різними варіаціями Але такий варіант був би найпростішим.
Про те, він не є добрим тому що тоді завдання у нас буде лише одне і ми його зможемо лише зробити або ще у процесі розробки ми можемо додати до нього є функціонал, в.
Все ж таки, можемо.
Прибрати. Ось це.
Завдання, поки що?
І повертаючи до все ж таки створення інфраструктури, і тут не з'являється степ і ми вказуємо що це користувацька історія можна його змінити але ми поки що лежить і далі ми зможемо створювати вже конкретно завдання.
По перше, завдання, яке я вказував це буде все ж таки створити так.
Турейтер поздорів і тут ми можемо також передати це завдання основою цього всього є ще завдання.
Це того, хто буде виконувати завдання. І ми можемо вказати що наприклад, це може бути станіслав який може виконувати це завдання.
Загалом, це можна обирати в кожної команді окремо Ви можете в команді, вирішувати хто хоче якесь завдання вимоги.
Що ця людина має робити таке завдання, ні, тут ви можете їх розподіляти по тому як вам буде зручно.
Загалом, створення інфраструктури Сюди можна віднести Якщо у вас немає відповідного програмного забезпечення.
Так. Також можна Сюди віднести завдання для кожного Тобто кожен може собі створити встановити більшого.
прокладом коли ми беремо завдання, і користувача. Історія закривається тоді, коли всі завдання, які та не відносяться є виконані.
На тут можна додавати так що вони співвідносяться Проте, тут лише що вони заблоковані, наприклад, конкретним завданням тобто немає прямої можливості.
На жаль, співвідносити завдання в а самі.
Тому будемо працювати з таким прикладом Загалом, що хотілось би побачити, також на наступне заняття і що ви могли б спробувати це обговорити групою які саме вам потрібні будуть завдання, Тобто ви можете обговорити тут.
Досить маленький. Може так. Це трошки, скверне. Яким вам конкретно, треба буде задаль користувача, історія як було вказано мають бути досить невеликими технічна сутність.
користувацьких історій буде те, що ми можемо казати Наприклад, розробити меню блог.
Меню або посилання тобто на основі цього можна буде створювати задачу або ж навіть якщо це буде користувача, історія можна створити одне за завдання лише до неї і це також буде цілком нормально.
А загалом я думаю, що по Асані це поки що все.
Е як було вказано загалом щодо наступного заняття вам треба буде зробити спробувати це все ж таки, спробувати створити користувацькі історії?
Далі вже стосовно цього створювати відповідні завдання.
Треба? Що по часу. Ми майже вже печерпуємо, на жаль, більше показати конкретно по віжолту.
Не встигнемо конкретно по тому як користуватися кіт-хабом, але я думаю, що це можна буде додати в частину наступного заняття.
І Загалом, завдання, я думаю, додамо, і не впевнений, що в мене є доступ поки що я щоб додати це під завданням конкретно щоб домашнє було прозорості, бачите, можна.
наступну зустріч.
До мене, питань краще чітко.
Станіслав у вас було запитань.
Ні, це я не випадково.
Ну, давайте не випадково спробуємо як то кажуть не побажати всім здоров'я, не гарних вихідних і зустрінемося згідно тих пропозицій що були надані за розкладом узгодимо до податково у телеграмі коли в нас буде стандарт з невеличкими, доповненнями, які ми сьогодні не встигли.
На все добре. І всім, Дякую.
Так. До побачення.
Дякую.
Дякую. До побачення.